en este vídeo quiero dar una pequeña
introducción para pensar más o menos
cuánto vale algo para saber dónde
podemos invertir nuestro dinero y cómo
le podemos hacer para pensar distintas
opciones de inversión o sea si nos
conviene más depositar el dinero en el
banco o comprar una casa o incluso pagar
las tarjetas de crédito para ya no andar
pagando tanto entonces para eso voy a
hablar acerca del retorno sobre capital
le voy a poner aquí retorno sobre sobre
capital
vital entonces va a ser un vídeo muy
sencillo no nos vamos a pegar a las
reglas de contabilidad todavía así que
únicamente vamos a pensar el retorno
sobre capital retorno sobre capital como
la cantidad de efectivo obtenido en el
año entonces le voy a poner efectivo
ganado por año ganado por año por año /
que le voy a poner la raya de dividido
entre el efectivo invertido efectivo
invertido
igual por año vale por año bueno
entonces fíjate aquí le puse ere o se ve
las siglas vienen en inglés es retorno
en capital pero es básicamente el
retorno sobre capital y entonces vamos a
ver un pequeño ejemplo va entonces
pues supongamos que tengo una cierta
idea y mi idea es abrir un restaurante
entonces voy a poner aquí un restaurante
restaurante sin embargo para abrir ese
restaurante lo que tengo que hacer es
pagar un millón de pesos para realizar
mis primeras inversiones y todo el suba
entonces le voy a poner aquí que la
inversión es de un millón un millón de
pesos
ok ahora supongamos que cada año así
después de pagar todo todo lo que tenga
que pagar ganamos cien mil pesos
entonces aquí le voy a poner ganancia
para poner así ganancia y le voy a poner
100 mil pesos 100 mil pesos esto ya es
después de pagarle a los meseros y
después de pagar la comida la materia
prima después de pagar los impuestos
esto es ya hasta el final cuánto puedo
yo quedarme ya para meterlo en mi
bolsillo entonces esta es la inversión
esta es la ganancia
si queremos calcular el retorno sobre
capital retorno sobre capital
básicamente hay que hacer la división
100.000 entre un millón 100 mil es el
10% de un millón entonces aquí nos
quedaría 10% 10% ok esto está muy
sencillito a lo mejor te estás
preguntando por qué estoy viendo este
vídeo porque estoy perdiendo el tiempo
aquí pero ahorita vamos a pasar a ideas
un poquito más complicadas ale entonces
va por el momento tenemos un restaurant
que nos garantiza tener un retorno sobre
capital del 10% ahorita no estamos
metiendo nada de riesgo y por tanto es
segurísimo obtener esto de acá pero
pensemos que hay más opciones imaginemos
que además de poder hacer un restaurant
se me presenta la oportunidad de abrir
que será nos vamos a pensar que un salón
de belleza va entonces le pongo aquí
salón salón de belleza
belleza por decir algo de modo similar
pensemos que la inversión que
necesitamos hacer es de un millón de
pesos sin embargo pues como es un salón
de belleza no tiene tanto éxito como el
restaurant no es tan famoso y nada más
nos deja 50 mil pesos al año otra vez
después de ya quitar todos los gastos
entonces ahí va una siguiente pregunta
cuál de estos es mejor pues claramente
restaurant verdad se ve desde desde acá
arriba y ya está acá arriba invertimos
un millón y ganamos cien mil al año
acá un millón ni ganamos sólo cincuenta
mil y eso también se refleja en el
retorno sobre capital que acá nada más
es de 5 por ciento 50 mil entre un
millón
entonces en general así ya después de
tomar en cuenta el riesgo y de ajustar
las cosas para para tomarlo en cuenta
entonces usualmente vamos a preferir el
negocio que tenga un mejor retorno sobre
capital digo en general porque hay
algunos detallitos verdad a lo mejor si
éste fuera 5% y éste fuera 6% pero nos
dan pues el dinero más frecuentemente en
el salón de belleza nos conviene más
tener el salón de belleza entonces bueno
y estas son algunas observaciones pero
ahora yo digo sigo diciendo cosas muy
fáciles pero ahora mi pregunta es
realmente queremos el restaurante diego
o sea hasta aquí parece ser que si nos
deja más dinero pero tenemos que tener
algo en cuenta a lo mejor no tenemos
este un millón de pesos para invertir y
tenemos que pedir un préstamo bancario
entonces lo que quiero hacer ahorita es
platicar acerca del costo del capital
aquí le voy a poner el costo del capital
capital muy bien entonces a qué me
refiero con esto pues justo eso a lo
mejor no tengo el un millón de pesos
para abrir este restaurant sin embargo
pues yo si se hace en un restaurant así
que puedo ir al banco los puedo
convencer de que mi comida es buenísima
y a lo mejor el banco dice a silva yo te
voy a dar tu préstamo para el
restaurante pero va a ser un préstamo
del 15% anual a qué se refiere esto pues
se refiere a que cada año tengo que
pagar el 15 por ciento de lo que me
presten entonces déjame ponerle aquí
digo este es el costo de capital digamos
en términos de la tasa
voy a poner aquí la tasa pero el costo
del capital ya digamos en efectivo
cuánto sería pues si tengo que pagar un
15% anual entonces ahora tengo que pagar
un 15% de un millón de pesos de este
modo cada año tengo que pagar 150 mil
pesos entonces la pregunta es realmente
me conviene ahora seguir haciendo este
restaurante digo nos deja un retorno
sobre capital del 10% que está muy bueno
incluso comparado con el salón de
belleza pero ahora estamos pagando 150
mil al año entonces obviamente aquí ya
no es buena idea no voy a poner así ya
no es buena idea hacer el restaurante
porque de hacerlo estamos tomando un
préstamo de 150 mil sólo ganamos 100.000
y por tanto cada año pues estamos
quemando 50 mil pesos así de la nada
verdad pagando se los al banco y
realmente no estamos ganando entonces
usualmente un buen negocio lo voy a
poner aquí un buen negocio
bocio déjame le pongo una carita feliz
de que es bueno en un negocio que si
queremos hacer es aquel en el cual el
retorno sobre capital es mayor que el
costo del capital va entonces aquí no
nos conviene hacer este negocio porque
estamos pagando más de lo que ganamos
bueno vamos a pensar cuál sería el caso
opuesto a lo mejor para cuando tú
quieres hacer tu salón de belleza pues
es una época magnífica para salones de
belleza porque el gobierno decidió que
necesitamos más salones de belleza en la
ciudad así que habría un cierto programa
gubernamental con el cual puedes ir y
pedir un préstamo pues así muy bajo un
préstamo para únicamente para abrir
salones de belleza del 2% para entonces
tú dices mira yo voy a hacer mi salón de
belleza y ya lo registre y este préstamo
va a ser sólo del 2% entonces aquí ya
ajax como que se voltea la balanza
verdad vamos a hacer las cuentas en este
caso estamos esté otra vez pidiendo un
préstamo de 1 millón de pesos el cual
sólo pagamos 2% así que el costo
capital ya en efectivo cada año sería de
20 mil pesos 20 mil pesos y entonces qué
sucede acá arriba perdíamos 50 mil pesos
cada año sin embargo aquí pues tenemos
50 mil pesos y estamos restando de estos
20 mil pesos así que de todas formas
nada más de todas formas nos quedan 30
mil pesos de ganancia entonces observa
el restaurante podría parecer una muy
buena idea al principio porque tenía un
retorno sobre capital muy alto pero
ahora el salón de belleza ya se ve mucho
mejor porque es el único de las dos
opciones que realmente nos está
generando un flujo positivo de efectivo
muy bien entonces hasta aquí le vamos a
dejar a esta pequeña introducción de
retorno sobre capital y del costo del
capital y en la siguiente y en otras más
pues platicaremos algunos ejemplos
porque a lo mejor esto de aquí ya se
murió verdad que esto no se haga pero
hay muchísimas personas que actualmente
están realizando cosas de este tipo de
este estilo y sobre todo en el mercado
pues en el mercado hipotecario en el
mercado inmobiliario sale
hasta aquí le dejamos y en los
siguientes vídeos vamos a ver algunos
ejemplos concretos de esto de acá